most crimes are 100% recidivist 'ok yet
they still let him out knowing damn well
they're gonna commit those crimes again
or in the case of the texas shooter the
the u.s. navy knew what a dirtbag what a
dangerous weirdo zombies son of a [ __ ]
this guy was and they didn't report the
indicators of weird zombies son of a
[ __ ] activities that the guy was guilty
on it's been a while i'm still a little
upset with him because i was planning on
going hunting with him from a helicopter
last time he floated the ideas were
excited about it and now he appears to
be calling from what is a small gift
giver of ideas a small Cabela's filled
with with dogs or is this is this your
own humble abode mr. Nugent yeah I don't
believe in our man caves I get a man's
Cuckoo's Nest I got more debris and more
sporting goods and more weaponry than
all the sporting goods and military
Arsenal's combined I get high on
gunpowder stink so this is this [ __ ]
what is this this your garage it's just
a shed that's just I mean I'm seeing
like nine bows behind you I don't know
what that is it's insane nothing I don't
know man I think there's like 90 look up
on that wall no I'm in my shop in the
swamps of Michigan this is where I've
accumulated 69 years of cocked locked
and ready to rock the Glock doc outdoor
celebrations so I got a lot of bows and
arrows and I wish I could show you the
buck Pole that we just took all the deer
down it from and gave away their
carcasses to our friends and neighbors
we had a sagging white-tailed deer buck
ball here at the Nugent swamp so I'm a
pretty happy son of a [ __ ] right I
could have he's almost with the rhymes
he's like a firearm
Muhammad Ali no I want to see a mash up
of him and diamond itself awesome
that would be so listen what do you say
because this question is going out when
someone says why do you need 10 assault
weapons Ted why do you need 10 compound
bows that's a question that's really
popular right now in the wake of a man
saving people's lives with his uh
assault weapon to be clear well it's not
a bill of needs it's a bill of rights
and uh 10 billions billions of America I
don't know anybody that doesn't own 25
to a hundred
25 firearms we like firearms they got
more than one blowtorch
I got enough horsepower in the other 2
cos Al Gore to have a heart attack every
two minutes I got a Jack Roush fired
bill strop Ford Bronco out there with
850 horsepower and I've got it tuned up
so it goes exactly 625 yards to the
gallon but my point is sodas outdoors so
it has back in man
I'm a [ __ ] I mean I haven't got diddly
I mean this is this is only my shot ammo
supply behind me here I only have I'm
down to my last I think 600,000 rounds
why not because when the family shoots
sometimes we go full auto and we'll
shoot a couple thousand rounds in an
hour and when we'd spread in and have
competition and have fun and the bottom
line is I have all that horsepower but
don't mess with me till I break the
speed limit we're in all of us that have
the Hellcats and high horsepower
machines which I think everybody I know
does you can't mess with us because our
cars might go fast you have to wait for
him to go fasters give us a ticket well
I ever think that the reason everyone
you know has high horsepower vehicles
and over 600 weapons is because you took
out the ones who didn't is there is
there some selection that goes on there
well I think the cream goes to the top
and those of us didn't celebrate the
American Dream we know how to live
hada you know we don't buy junk we buy
firepower and and in hunting supplies
it's just my lifestyle I've been doing
this for 69 years I've never missed a
hunting season in 69 years and I'm I am
so solidly in the asset column I'm
almost like Mother Teresa with ammo I
mean the venison that I distribute to
homeless shelters and soup kitchens and
the vets and to neighbors and friends I
mean I'm doing God's work here so those
that would criticize me because I do too
much God's work might want to kiss my
hind quarter yeah I think Al Gore might
be lining up and by the way just for
future reference you don't need to help
him with any of the heart attacks I
think he's got those bases covered on
his own he goes in for a Swedish massage
that's why he's patrolling every time he
cuts himself shaving it just spills out
exactly I don't know how he still
managed to have a cordon area without a
heart no with a marvel of science
mystery so obviously mr. Nugent after
the shooting that occurred in Texas we
had we just so happen to be lucky where
man's daughter was a fan of the show so
we had an exclusive with Steven
Williford on this show he didn't want to
do any other media no one in the media
to this day I know has covered that
Stephen Wilford protected people with
his ar-15 the narrative has been
mind-numbing to the point where if I've
said this if my reasoning is reductive
it's because the only it's the only way
I know to process for example the
domestic violence loophole by the way
Casey Owens widened the loophole is just
he broke the law so if you even have you
been following this and in the media
back how predictable is it and the one
thing the one question I want is only
non is is it disturbingly trending right
now to see that the media really moves
on from the coverage and we don't hear a
lot of information in the wake of these
it seems like politicization immediately
well number one Stephen we the people of
Cruz logic and common sense and goodwill
and decency and law and order we salute
you for bringing that truth to the
forefront I'm well aware of what you're
doing out there that's why we're here
today together because my friends and I
have decided that you deserve me because
we guessed truth logic and common sense
you know when that happened I went to
the military and law enforcement guys
and a bunch of NRA guys and we always
know those of us that are not you know
brainwashed and propagandized by the
fake news orgy of what used to be
journalism and the the anti education of
academia and the criminal enterprise of
the Democrat Party and all things
therein we know that it's never about
hardware it's about bureaucratic failure
and this is a clip but the US Navy and I
got a bunch of Navy buddies I trained
with the seals and marcus luttrell is my
dear friend and blood brother so these
are my close kin but that the US Navy is
a Burin
bureaucracy which of course is
responsible for colliding ships and
craters that's my dog you have him as a
guard dog in the studio so we know
there's never a matter of hardware
access because when I was first born in
1948 you get a Thompson submachine gun
through the Sears mail or
catalog delivered to your door for like
94 dollars and there was unlimited
access to firepower then and none of
this ever happened because the dumbing
down of America has manifested itself in
a cultural deprivation and abandonment
of what made America great and that as
neighbors really caring about neighbors
and people adhering to the Ten
Commandments the Golden Rule the
Constitution the Bill of Rights and a
sense of decency and accountability with
the people in our lives and afraid and
even though that's alive and well it's
everywhere across America all that
wonderful good and positive is
everywhere but you have the occasional
dirt bag out there where there's Las
Vegas or Sandy Hook or in Sulphur in
Texas
those are aberrations and we should
never be controlled and regulated based
on the criminal activity of freaks that
has been facilitated by the US
government
write this down Stephen the crime rate
in this country is here it is engineered
recidivism it's engineered recidivism by
our failed court system that knows that
most crimes are 100 percent recidivist
'ok yet they still let them out knowing
damn well they're going to commit those
crimes again or in the case of the texas
shooter the the u.s. navy knew what a
dirtbag what a dangerous weirdo zombie
son of a [ __ ] this guy was and they
didn't report the indicators of weird
zombies son of a [ __ ] activities that
the guy was guilty on so the results are
predictable right it's kind of like the
Charlie Sheen sex offender news coming
out and saying well up is down down is
up it's not as though you could say we
didn't see this one coming this is a
scenario where they should have by the
way plus one for Sears catalog reference
Jerrod is too young for that Sears
catalog it's where you could purchase a
firearm minibike and that back then is
where you looked at women's lingerie I
had them stuffed under my best JC Penney
got a little more racy in the 90s so
when I consider myself fortunate young
man you know it's a real it's a point is
owning on there Ted the the lack of
education I've always that this issue
takes place between gun owners and the
ignorant I think was Samantha B just
saying listen 94% of Americans support
some support gun control no no the poll
is 94 percent of Americans
support background checks well if you
ask everyone here all firearm owners we
say well sure we support the background
checks which are already in place they
take that and say 94% support an assault
weapons ban it's a bait and switch that
is proactive and it leaves no room
anymore for the possibility that they're
ignorant I mean I've got to imagine as a
guy who's an enthusiast yourself who's
in the know it drives you you nuts well
again what nobody will ever state and
I'll say it right here on a
communication network that does
celebrate and drive home truth logic and
common sense the National instant check
background system was authored by the
National Rifle Association of America
because it was a cop dense maneuver that
that stopped the wrong people from
getting well theoretically would stop
the drug people from getting guns but
the bad guys don't seem to care about
having instant check or long-range
tracker waiting periods or gun got
buyback programs bottom line is Stephen
that up appears to be down and down
appears to be up if you if you watch
most of the media and if you listen to
the left wingers but let me tell you I
just said goodbye to a bunch of great
families here in Michigan they went home
after a great deer hunt we raise money
for the military charities we raise
money for the children's charities and
generous loving giving hard-working
American families who bust their ass to
be in the asset column they give and
give and give and I've never met a
person I just did the greatest tour of
my life did fifty-three unbelievable
rock outs in 68 days and I miss people
every day and they're like you and me
logic common sense directed by
self-evident truth and all those pillars
of quality of life again the
Constitution to build a right Bam's the
golden rule
a sense of decency law abiding law and
order it is alive and well all across
this country I'm surrounded by these
guys and gals every day at my dear camp
in Michigan I'm on my way to Texas so I
know that weirdos exist I know that
zombies exist to think that animals have
rights and that if you ban guns that but
believe me sensible educated
common-sense Americans outnumber though
dirtbags in a you know in a huge way so
feel confident that when you say Happy
Thanksgiving here in a couple weeks that
we can still give thanks that we the
people are on the right track we're on a
True North compass setting but we can't
let legislation be directed by some
dirtbag who shot up a bunch of innocent
people in a church because the US Navy
forgot to mention that he was a dirtbag
yeah I know Jared you you you guys it's
such the weirdos that we outnumber it's
it's the it's the everyday leftist
activists to that it's a smokescreen to
make you think there are huge numbers
that's why anyone show up at the screen
with the sky event there's more press to
cover the scream at the sky the actual
protests report does it was so silly we
have to get going here cuz III know Ted
is busy and we we have a Ben Shapiro
coming up but yeah you know that's a big
reason Michigan went red I love that
video you talk about how Michigan came
home one of the biggest issues was
firearms because a lot of Democrats who
were hunters in the Midwest and Michigan
and Hillary Clinton was seen as so
rapidly anti-gun so when I see this I
say you know what lay it on a little
thicker CNN to keep it coming because
you're gonna keep on losing these blue
states it's your single biggest losing
issue mr. Nugent where's the best place
for people to find you I know you just
finished up this kick-ass tour but what
should people be looking for well I have
a wonderful Facebook I have millions and
millions of people on Facebook we
communicate every day and you can see
that positive spirit and positive energy
and the love and the goodwill and the
effervescence that is all things uncle
Ted it just blows up I look forward to
people because when the dirt bag surface
it's kind of fun to have a punching bag
of stupidity and we have a lot of fun
with that so you're right Democrats stay
on course you're providing us more humor
than Richard Pryor's afro ignited this
is great time
yes and there you go he's like post
redemption Ebenezer Scrooge only he
shoots animals Oh
you like this video subscribe by
clicking the button that says subscribe
if you're not aware of it now there's no
way you're learning the Internet at this
point I'm not going to help you but this
was clipped from my daily show available
exclusively to lotto with credit com /
mug club members of your student
military or veteran internet promo code
it's less than six dollars a month and
you get daily content no more clips Plus
this hand etched mug oh I just when I
feel it I got a chill like on the inside